quelques points d'éclaircissement avec m
ghislaine bacha que vous n'êtes que vous
vous entendez à isabel richer ma
collègue régulièrement m bacha bonsoir
bon sens bon je le disais pour nous ces
étrangers est que des jurés
soient dans un procès civil ça existe au
canada n'est ce pas non ça n'existe pas
au civil il était certes cinq hommes de
deux femmes le soir ils rentrer chez eux
nous on a des jurés des affaires
criminelles sont séquestrés pendant
délibéré on est vraiment dans l'autre
univers bon est-ce que y'a possible des
possibilités d'appel maintenant
oui c'est sûr que je pense entre autres
à madame heures de pourrait porter en
appel lui ce qui plaidait en trois
points le rapidement c'est que ce
qu'elle avait tout inventé que dans le
fond le premier amendement l'absolu ce
qui coupe la liberté d'expression ça
s'applique pas aux menteurs est il de
même excusez moi c'est pas très élégant
comme argument mais il disait elle a
tout inventé les malicieuses parce que
c'est bon c'est d'un système de niveau 2
les producteurs qui s'engagent des
victimes de mythes ou alors je pense que
l qui plaidait entre autres bons que ce
n'était pas assez mais aussi tout un
message à envoyer aux femmes pour
toujours plus de preuves gestion de
photos 42 films se sera pas suffisant ça
pourrait être motif qu'elle souhaite
soulever pour un autre les mais
contrairement à procès criminel ici où
le doute raisonnable rend non coupable
quelqu'un là c'est la prépondérance des
preuves autrement dit ils ont pas
vraiment cru la version madame heures et
demie avait pas besoin d'être 100%
convaincu qu'elle mentait c'était plus
probable calme en atteste un peu ça
l'idée là tout à fait alors c'est
d'ailleurs c'est pour ce magazine et son
état est en virginie parce qu'il ya ce
fardeau de preuve là il n'y avait
personne en angleterre parce que c'était
une espèce de hors de tout doute même où
6000 mai donc c'est un fardeau qui était
quand même
que passe-t-il si on peut dire pour
monsieur jack donc le les jurés n'ont
pas cru qu'elle avait été battue qu'elle
avait été victime de violences
conjugales et par conséquent quand elle
écrit cette lettre dans le washington
post où elle dénonce
comme victime dit il faut que les femmes
se lèvent et cetera ça doit cesser ils
disent ça c'est de la diffamation parce
qu'il n'ya pas de substances penser les
jurés tout à fait parce que c'est la
même chose ici au québec un procès en
diffamation se voit sa main cache
toujours un autre morceau parle pas de
formation dans les airs il faut ensuite
regardé gratter l'histoire existe une
histoire de coupe toxiques de violences
conjugales alors c'est moi ce qui m'a
étonné si vous permettez c'est que non
seulement elle est responsable dans la
lettre ouverte elodie famille en disant
j'ai vécu cette expérience ça donne
quand même bitume mais elles mêmes
tenues
responsables de formation pour le titre
du journal puis vous le savez dans votre
domaine ne s'est pas déjà créatures des
sept spéciales du tout du tout mais elle
avait 28 et alors ça aussi ça peut être
un motif d'appel on n'est pas
nécessairement aux états unis
responsables des retweets est ce que
plaide
est ce que c'est une victoire est ce que
c'est une victoire totale pour monsieur
des parce qu'il doit lui aussi compte
tenu d'une déclaration d'un de ses
avocats qu'il accusait madame heureuse
d'avoir que c'était un que c'était un
coup monté il doit payer 2 millions
alors est ce que c'est une victoire
partagée aussi une nette victoire pour
monsieur
johnny depp semaine victoire pour lui la
phase là pour laquelle elle la gaani
l'avocat elle dit à l'ap et le policier
ils sont repartis pas contente de ça le
prix du vin est là on a mis un peu
partout elle saccagé elle mais alors si
cette phrase qui était peut-être un peu
de trop un peu trop factuel et peut-être
que ce serait peut-être savait pas été
du tout prouvé d'un procès donc elle
gagne quand même minime par rapport à
toute l'histoire une six semaines une
centaine d'heures que de preuve qu'on a
entendu donc nette victoire pour johnny
depp qu'est ce que vous pensez en
terminant m bacha qui ont le voile sur
réseaux sociaux pia
y'a des kpi déjà ça sans égal mais les
gens qui disent et un recul pour le mime
le mouvement mis tout qu'est ce que vous
répondez à ça
je trouvais que l'avocat de madame
n'était vraiment combien là dessus on
sent qu est ce que ça va prendre de plus
une photo de plus elle en avait un
rendez-vous médical depuis je sais le
médecin elle en avait alors ça rejoint
aussi mon monde juridique c'est-à-dire
que si pour me tout pour les procès mais
même pour le mouvement général c'est
c'est pas quelque chose qui va aider le
mouvement ces mails peuvent être très
très très froid 10 mètres ghislaine
bachand avocats et avocates merci
beaucoup à vous avez suivi tout ce long
procès merci de nous avons parlé ce prix
au revoir